is there some degree on the human
psychology side that
resentment because of how because of
what happened after World War I led to
Hitler wielding so much power and then
Hitler starting World War II so this is
the The Human Side perhaps the reason I
asked that question is also because you
mentioned the century of humiliation on
the China side so to so to which degree
the
humiliation
lead to Hitler and lead to World War I
well the question what led to Hitler is
a very different question than the
question of what led to World War II
once Hitler was in power I mean after
January 30th 1933 he's in power and then
the question of what is driving him
comes racing to the four uh is there
resentment over the verai treaty and
what happened to Germany yes did that
matter yes but my argument is that
structure was the principal Factor uh
driving the train in in Hitler's case
but what I'm saying here is that there
were other factors at well as well
resentment being one of them will to
power or the fact that he was A
congenital aggressor in my lexicon uh
certainly mattered as well so I I don't
want to dismiss um your point uh about
resentment so Hitler in particular the
way he wielded the way he gained so much
power might have
been the general resentment of the
populace of the German populace I think
that uh as a result of um defea in World
War I and all the trials and
tribulations associated with viar
Germany and then the coming of uh the
Great Depression all of those factors
definitely account for his coming to
power I think that one of the
reasons um that he was so successful at
winning over the German people once he
came to
power uh was because there was a great
deal of resentment uh in the German body
politic and he played on that resentment
that Surly helped them get elected too
but I think having studied the case it
was even more important once he took
over I also believe that one of the
principal reasons that he was so popular
and he was wildly popular inside Nazi
Germany is because he was the only
leader of an industrialized country who
pulled his country out of
depression uh and that really
mattered uh and uh it made him uh very
effective it's also worth noting that he
was a remarkably charismatic individual
uh I find that hard to believe because
every time I look at him or listen to
his speeches uh he does not appear to be
charismatic to me but uh I've talked to
a number of people who are experts on
this subject who assure me that he was
very charismatic and I would note to you
if you look at public opinion polls in
Germany West Germany in the late 1940s
this is the late 1940s after the Third
Reich is destroyed in
1945 he is still remarkably popular in
the
polls